all right welcome to cbs mornings we're
going to begin in washington where
president biden is pushing fellow
democrats to unite amid disagreements in
his own party over domestic policy goals
mr biden met with house and senate
democrats yesterday to work on two very
big pieces of legislation a trillion
dollar infrastructure bill and a larger
about 3.5 trillion dollar spending bill
social infrastructure it's been called
two moderate senate democrats joe
manchin and kristen cinema say the three
and a half trillion dollar cost of that
second bill is simply too high now the
bill cannot pass without their support
senate budget committee chairman bernie
sanders joins us from capitol hill for
an exclusive interview he was one of the
lawmakers who met with the president
yesterday senator good morning to you uh
your party's in a difficult spot right
here you've got as much as four and a
half trillion all told that could go to
the american people everything from
roads and bridges to child care and
health care and it's all held up how'd
that meeting go with the president
yesterday listen tony what we are trying
to do is pass the most consequential
piece of legislation for working
families since the 1930s what's
happening in america as i think most
people know is the very rich are
becoming much richer while working
families are struggling and what we are
saying is maybe just maybe now is the
time for government to represent
ordinary people not just wealthy
campaign contributors and what we are
running into is enormous opposition from
the drug companies because they don't
want to have us lower the cost of
prescription drugs the healthcare
industry surely does not us want us to
expand medicare to cover dental
eyeglasses and hearing aids the fossil
fuel industry doesn't want us to tackle
climate change this is a consequential
and enormous struggle we're going to win
it
well senator i'm sure lobbying is going
on as it always does but you're also
running into opposition within your own
party you've got at least two senators
who say they will not vote for three and
a half trillion dollars meanwhile in the
house you've got progressives saying if
that doesn't pass they won't vote for
the infrastructure bill and everything
is in a standstill would you take
leftovers in the senate tony tony look
you know we got 50 members of the united
states senate we're getting zero support
from the republicans who do not want to
lower the cost of prescription drugs
they don't want to make community
colleges tuition-free they want to give
tax breaks to their billionaire friends
we got 50 people we can't lose one so
what we are trying to do is negotiate
and i think at the end of the day we are
going to come up with an agreement now
you ask me about compromise i have
compromised the bill that should have
been passed in my judgment was a six
trillion dollar bill if you take climate
change into consideration that's the
kind of money that we need we've already
made a significant uh compromise
consider a number less than 3.5 trillion
dollars right look we're talking about
numbers you tell me what we should cut
tell the working families of this
country that we don't need to make it
make child care affordable tell the
american people and the younger people
that we should not address the crisis of
climate change and try to save the
planet tell the homeless people that we
should not build affordable housing
tell the young people that we should not
make community colleges tuition free all
we are trying to do is address the
crises facing working families and
demand that the wealthiest people in
this country start paying their fair
share of taxes they are fighting back
big time but at the end of the day i
believe we're going to prevail
but we also know senator listen all of
the causes you state are all very worthy
we all get it you don't want to cut any
of them but it gets to the point that
you have to get things done so what are
you willing to do what have you said to
joe manchin have you been talking to him
look there's been an enormous amount of
discussion let me repeat
i originally and what the overwhelming
majority of members of the democratic
caucus want is a six trillion dollar
bill we have already made a significant
compromise now the president is i was in
the white house yesterday president is
doing a very good job trying to bring
people together we will see what happens
but right now we have got to address the
needs of working family and finally
finally have the guts to stand up to the
big money interests who have so much
power in this country
but senator if you're here today saying
you're not willing to take less than
three and a half trillion it sounds like
it sounds like this is not going to
happen
now you know let me let me rephrase your
question tony
after poll tells me and tells you that
what we are trying to do is enormously
popular every single issue has
widespread support not only from
democrats but for republicans and
independents
and i think maybe it's time that we
stood up for the working families of
this country and not from the for the
drug companies and the health insurance
industry and the fossil fuel industry so
that's the fight we're in now at the end
of the day i think we're going to
succeed in passing an enormously
important piece of legislation for
working families
senator you're mentioning working
families we're a week away from the
government shutting down which means
hundreds of thousands of government
workers will not get paychecks during a
pandemic which has already rocked our
country what does the situation look
like in the senate averting the
government shutdown well that's a great
question and obviously nobody wants a
shutdown but once again i hope people
appreciate we are getting zero support
we got 50 members of the democratic
caucus 50 members of the republican
caucus we're getting zero support and at
this point although i suspect they will
change their mind
you don't have you have a republican
leadership not helping us even deal with
the debt with the uh raising the debt
ceiling which would plunge the entire
planet into an economic uh depression so
you know we have we have a handful here
with important issues at the end of the
day i think we will succeed
it just seems a very frustrating place
right now on capitol hill let's talk
about
it seems so senator let's talk about
police reforms it didn't pass yesterday
despite enormous effort bipartisan
effort you had tim scott cory booker
karen bass working on it seemed to have
momentum after the death of george floyd
well you talk about enormous enormous
bipartisan effort that's not true i mean
let's be clear you got a republican
party which has become a right-wing
extremist party cory booker has done a
great job trying to bring people
together on basic fundamental issues of
police reform we have gotten virtually
no support from republicans and i hope
people understand this
the republican party right now is giving
us zero support and taking on the drug
companies giving us zero support in
terms of raising the debt ceiling zero
support in terms of trying to prevent a
government shutdown
senator you're right you're right you're
right senator tim scott doesn't really
represent enormous uh republicans right
support you're right about that but the
fact is you did have senators on both
sides trying to make a deal it did
appear to have momentum some kind of
momentum after the murder of george
floyd and if you can't get it passed
after something as horrific as that when
the democrats are in control of the
senate and and and the and the white
house
what will it take to get police reform
in this country on a federal level yeah
let's be clear about it you know we
didn't talk even about voting rights
right we didn't talk about the
republican effort in georgia and texas
and other states to deny
people the right to vote most often
people of color young people people with
disabilities
yes the democrats have the majority we
have control over the senate but it's a
50-50 vote often you need 60 votes to
get things done we're getting zero
cooperation from republicans on major
issue after major issue
all right senator sanders it's always a
pleasure uh speaking with you you uh do
not hold back and we appreciate that and
we hope you will come back uh when
there's movement on this issue yeah okay
thank you very much